[Music]
my name is Michael Wheatley Ward I'm
director of the Sheraton theater
in broadstairs we're a receiving house
which means that we bring in tours small
concerts folk groups we do a lot of
community work fundraising for various
events and Charities but we also produce
in-house a couple of major things here
one is the Dickens Festival play in June
and the other is our Panama
we've been running These pantom Arms now
for 12 years they've increased each year
and Mother Goose is a favorite
and I have to say I'm very optimistic
about the bookings this year I mean
apart from obviously the financial side
it's a way of introducing new people to
the theater and not just kids but adults
as well it's amazing the amount of
adults and so we've never been in the
theater
our biggest names are our patrons Judy
Dench David suchet and Julian the
fellows but this is quite a workable
size we can get up to 200.
um but we space it out for most shows at
about 144
and we have Cabaret seating with tables
it is I mean I've always run
conventional proscenium the theaters
when I came here I was amazed at how you
can be more flexible so multi-use is the
way forward
foreign people are staying local I've
had the feedback that all passwords are
doing better in the general area the
smaller areas towns and Villages
obviously you can go to the bigger
theaters and see a lot of glitzy names
and
you're paying 50 pound a seat you go to
London you're paying a hundred pounds
but our duty is not only to support the
local community but also to keep live
entertainment going and it's rather like
an independent retailer you've got to
have independent shops to give Variety
in the area and we're quite pleased
around here that we do have a lot of
independent shops but they need
nurturing as much as theaters do
foreign